Hello everyone! My name is Georgi and I'm
one of the TAs for this course and in this
video I want to show you how to install GHC
and in particular the Haskell Platform. To
install, first we have to find the Haskell
Platform, so let us Google that. It's immediately
the first hit. On this website we are offered
the choice of the system that we want to install
on. I'm using a Mac right now, so I will click
on Mac. The download link is up here - Haskell
Platform 2014. I'm downloading it now. In
fact, I have already downloaded this file,
so let's just go ahead and click on it. The
installer starts by double clicking on it
and then we are presented with the usual menu.
We click on continue. It takes more than 1GB
of space, which we are more than happy to
use for Haskell. Then we click install.
We input our password to authorize Haskell to
install and wait for it to finish.
There it is! It also redirects us to the documentation
page for the Haskell Platform where you can
read up on all the ins and outs and the things
you can do with it. So let's start with some
simple examples. I have 2 prompts open here.
In one I will open up my editor - which is,
of course, vi. I have a file called test.hs
- recall that .hs is the extension for Haskell
files. In this file I have defined 2 functions,
as mentioned in the lecture, double and quadruple.
Now I would like to see them in action, so
I type "ghci test.hs". We see a lot of text being
printed out, but the most important thing
is right here - Ok, modules loaded: Main.
Now we can start testing the functions by
simply typing in their name: double 10, which
makes it 20. Also notice that we can use tab
completion. So for quadruple 30 we get 120.
Let's go back to the editor that we have on
the left and simply add 2 new functions as
we have also seen in the lecture, in this
case: factorial and average.
GHCi is still running in our case and all we need to do
to load the new functions is type :reload.
GHCi tells us that everything went ok, so
now we can go ahead and test these functions.
Let's say factorial of 10.
Something's not going right! My bad!
I haven't saved the file
yet, so I do need to save it before it can
be reloaded. I reload once again. Modules
are loaded. Now I try factorial of 10 and
I get the right answer. Let's try average
of a list of 1, 2, 3, 4 and 5. I get the number 3.
This is a very simple introduction to how
to install the Haskell Platform, how to use
it, how to load files and how to start editing.
Thank you!